just how bad is Michael a vanetti he's
so bad he gives lawyers a bad name a
California judge not only ruled to
dismiss stormy Daniels defamation suit
against President Trump but also ordered
her to pay Trump's legal fees now when
judges do that it's the send a message
your lawyers a [ __ ] poor stormy as a
rule people pay her for sex
now Aven Eddie's reversed the charges
sleazy lawyers are often called
ambulance chasers Advan Eddie is worse
he chases spotlights and when he catches
them he looks ridiculous but he's good
at one thing costing his own side money
a few months ago his firm was ordered to
pay ten million bucks to an attorney who
once worked there and one of the
Cavanaugh debacle the gang rape
accusations arrived like the carnival
sideshow the media so badly wanted a
vanetti was the clown with the biggest
clip-on nose honking his little horn
then his disgusting ploy imploded and
the TV anchors who indulged him fled
sensing they were becoming his victims
too
but why complain he's been a gift for
the Republicans and a disaster for the
Democrats are we sure he wasn't on
Trump's payroll all along now a vanetti
has taken to challenging people to
fights on twitter like a town palooka
reliving past fights at the local bar so
how does a serial trickster get away
with it does the State Bar care about
ethics violations
isn't there a disciplinary committee or
is he exempt because he's a liberal
attack dog his punishment should be
harsh make him represent himself all
right though we do have he's gonna run
Dana I mean yeah he's running so maybe
this could be great for him he doesn't
care might be great for we're just being
selfish because he does provide a lot of
fodder I'm sure that Democrats wish he
would just go away right all right
become a Republican you could run with
Liz what a ticket yeah they could come
up with some other sort of cockamamie
exactly I do wonder if a vanetti will
actually help stormy Daniels pay the
actual legal fees oh the ballot is right
GoFundMe page which is you know flooded
with money from people who hate Trump
that's gonna end up going to trump right
exactly I don't know if that's true I
just read that right Twitter it's true
Jessie Trump always makes money one
where the is very rich I think the
Democrats have really hitched their ride
to the wrong horse here I'm not talking
about story I'm talking about a vanetti
because he's taking the Democrats for a
ride and it's not gonna be a victory lap
here and so the president obviously said
that she's a horse face or whatever on
Twitter and now everybody on the Left is
upset about that I wouldn't say that but
here's what I would say the left has
used the word C word to describe people
in the Trump family and then me
everybody applauded that they fantasize
about killing the president they call
him a fatso Nazi mental patient they
love that kind of language now all of a
sudden they're clutching their pearls
when the president says the word horse
face please
so be surprised now that Donald Trump
says bad things and uses dirty nicknames
about people three years later
either you haven't learned a thing after
the last three years or you're just
dense this is what he does and this is
how he wins and now regarding the other
claim about the gang rape case that
being so false in and of itself makes me
think maybe Donald Trump didn't have an
affair with stormy Daniels I would say
that stormy Daniels has also said some
not so nice things about President
Trump's appearance so he's kind of just
giving it very specific there systemic
things we will not repeat Ivan at2020 is
going to be lit as the kids say and I
think Democrats are really actually
pretty disappointed that he's gotten
involved here especially during the
Cavanaugh fight they think the reason
why they lost that is because he got
involved with these ridiculous
allegations and these statements that
were made and the bottom line is he's
putting stormy Daniels in a position
where she's probably not going to pay
these legal bills for her and he's going
to go and try and find some other woman
to jump into this trap of politics that
say no claiming he will represent her it
will be great they're going to win and
yet his track record shows exactly the
opposite so it's not good for women
getting involved warning if you see
avenatti knocking on your door say no
and tell them to go away and when it
comes to actual implications and
consequences for what you've done League
to be on TV town away
well don't filter the kids say his
campaign is lit let's mean it's like
like I'm fires going gonna be exciting
rocks oh I think I think Dana and Greg
had it right it'll be fun for us because
it's fun for us is ridiculous key to me
the the horseface stuff by the way yeah
I don't like come on this is I mean it's
you gotta say to me oh it's typical
trunk that's what he does with everybody
but you know remember Carly Fiorina
she's look at that face this woman's
horse face I just think man at some
point American woman and be like this
guy's out of concider with porn stars
want oh I see well I just think it's all
women is the terms of his attitude but I
think the real interesting thing is here
how the right is making this out to be
such a big win total vindication for
Donald Trump when this is not even the
main case the main case has to do with
the non-disclosure agreement this was
about that unknown guy in the parking
lot about the non-disclosure my point to
you is that this case is still pending
out there's not said right there here's
the issue this was the case that they
just are Trump this one was probably the
strongest one because she up to your
point about the hush agreement she took
the money it's gonna be really hard in
court to her her to be proven to be
wrong or uh right if she had taken the
money but it's not she said that in fact
it wasn't properly signed at Michael
Cohen who now I don't know where he
stands he doesn't I don't think he's
Democrat that's how ridiculous this is
where the conversation and not only this
day but in America has gone too
knotti had a relationship was involved
michael avenatti actually when had his
DNA tested 25% reptile to be higher I
thought yes